vamos a resolver algunos problemas de
rectas paralelas y transversales déjame
pintar aquí un par de rectas paralelas
para indicar que son paralelas voy a
marcar que tienen la misma dirección con
estas flechitas y además voy a dibujar
una transversal una recta que las corté
la voy a poner más o menos así un
poquito más inclinada más o menos así e
imagínate que nos dicen que este ángulo
de acá mide 60 grados este ángulo de acá
mide 60 grados y nos piden determinar el
valor de este ángulo de acá de este
ángulo de acá al principio puede parecer
un problema difícil porque este ángulo
está en una recta y este ángulo está en
otra pero recordando las cosas de líneas
paralelas sale muy sencillo hay varias
formas de hacerlo pero a mí lo que me
gusta primero es marcar los ángulos
correspondientes entonces si tenemos que
este ángulo es de 60 grados este de acá
también va a ser de 60 grados porque son
ángulos correspondientes con esta pareja
de líneas paralelas y con esta
transversal es como el ángulo que está
abajo a la derecha más o menos vale
entonces este ángulo de acá es de 60
grados
de 60 grados y ahora podemos utilizar
que este ángulo con el que no conocemos
forman un ángulo de 180 grados son
suplementarios porque forman esta línea
vale entonces con esa información
tenemos que este ángulo déjame llamarle
x x
+ 60 grados
60 grados es igual a 180 grados 180
grados y restando 60 grados de ambos
lados tenemos que x es igual a 120
grados vale entonces este ángulo es
igual a 120 grados y en realidad con
esta información parece muy poquita pero
con esta información podemos encontrar
ya todos los ángulos de la figura si
éste es de 120 grados este suplementario
entonces es de 60 grados o bien es
opuesto por el vértice a este entonces
desde 60 este es opuesto por el vértice
a éste la escribí acá entonces es de 120
grados y luego podemos seguir pues con
muchos argumentos por ejemplo este ahora
es correspondiente de este entonces mide
120 grados y es opuesto por el vértice
de este entonces son iguales también es
de 120 grados o bien éste es igual a
éste por ser correspondientes hay muchas
formas de decirlo y finalmente este es
de 60 grados por cualquiera de las
razones que ya hemos argumentado o
puesto por el vértice suplementario o
bien ser ángulo correspondiente vale
vamos a hacer otro problema déjame
trazar otras dos rectas voy a trazar una
recta morada y una recta rosa una recta
rosa más o menos algo como así vale
entonces ahí tenemos esta recta y esta
recta y pensemos que tienen una
transversal voy a poner por aquí la
transversal
más o menos algo así si así está bien
entonces entonces déjame poner un poco
más inclinada entonces imagínate que nos
dan esta información y además que este
ángulo de acá
que este ángulo de acá es de 50 grados
50 grados y este ángulo de acá que voy a
marcar en color naranja es de 120 grados
120 grados y ahora la pregunta es si
estas dos rectas son paralelas son
paralelas
ale las bueno pues vamos a pensar lo que
sucedería si estas dos rectas fueran
paralelas a lo mejor encontramos algún
problema a ver si estas dos rectas
fueran paralelas este ángulo sería
correspondiente con este de acá y por lo
tanto este ángulo sería de 50 grados
50 grados déjame ponerlo con un
asterisco porque no sabemos simplemente
estamos viendo qué sucede si fueran
paralelas pero si esté fuera de 50
grados ya tendríamos un problema porque
estos dos el de 50 y el de 120 tienen
que ser suplementarios en realidad
siempre tienen que ser suplementarios
verdad porque conforman la línea rosa
entonces si este fuera de 50 si está
fuera de 50 porque porque estas dos
estamos suponiendo que son paralelas
tendríamos que éste más este serial 170
grados pero necesitamos que sea 180
grados entonces eso es imposible creo
que se dice más bonito de la otra forma
o sea en vez de ponerle que éste mide 50
grados
primero utilizamos que estos son
suplementarios entonces lo que siempre
sabemos es esta propiedad verdad y así
tenemos una recta
una recta y tenemos cualquier otra recta
entonces este con este siempre suman 180
este con este suman 180 entonces
aplicando al aquí tenemos esta recta
rosa este es de 120 grados entonces este
de acá siempre siempre es de 60 grados
los voy a pintar en color verde siempre
es de 60 grados y por lo tanto estos dos
ángulos que son correspondientes no son
iguales y las rectas no pueden ser
paralelas vale porque si fueran
paralelas tendrían que ser los mismos
ángulos entonces llegamos a la
conclusión de que las rectas no pueden
ser paralelas porque si no tendríamos
que los ángulos correspondientes son
distintos y eso es imposible
saleh entonces le vamos a dejar hasta
aquí y seguimos con otros problemas en
los siguientes vídeos